हेलो
एवरीवन वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो आई एम ऑडिबल लाउड एंड
क्लियर सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है वेरी गुड
इवनिंग पढने एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग अभिषेक
हेलो आयुष थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं आज तो
मैंने आप लोगों की टाइमिंग के हिसाब से
अपनी क्लास को शेड्यूल किया है देखते हैं
कि आज कितने लोग आते
हैं वरना तो टाइम तो एक बहाना है ना आने
का क्लास
में क्या बात कर रहे हो साउंड नहीं है
यार होगा साउंड डेफिनेटली
होगा नहीं साउंड है
इससे ज्यादा क्या करूं माइक फुल पे
है यस जॉब ओरिएंटेड बैच है
क्लास अभी स्टार्ट कर देंगे नेक्स्ट ू
मिनट में थोड़ा सा और वेट करते हैं दे
ओनली 32 स्टूडेंट्स और अगर आज भी स्ट्रेंथ
32 ही
है तो फिर हमारा जो प्रीवियस टाइम है 7 ओ
क्लॉक का बेस्ट टाइमिंग है क्योंकि 7 ओ
क्लॉक भी उतनी स्ट्रेंथ है और 8:30 भी
उतनी स्ट्रेंथ है क्योंकि अभी तो सब लोग
फ्री हो जाते हैं बेसिकली अगर जो वर्किंग
प्रोफेशनल है अगर वो लेट ड्यूटी आता तो वो
भी अटेंड कर सकता है या ऑन ड्यूटी है तो
वो भी अटेंड कर सकता है क्योंकि यह ऐसा
टाइम होता है 8:30 का जहां पर ज्यादा
प्रेशर नहीं रहता काम का
टाइम इज बेस्ट बट वे द
स्टूडेंट तो मेरी प्रीवियस क्लास में जो
स्टार्टिंग से अभी तक जो भी स्टूडेंट आए
थे सभी आ
गए जल्दी से यस भेजिए चैट
में और जो न्यू स्टूडेंट है वह चैट में
न्यू लिखिए तो मुझे पता चल जाएगा कितने नए
स्टूडेंट और कितने ओल्ड स्टूडेंट
है क्लाउड फेयर की सिक्योरिटी टाइट है
अभी बताइए आप लोग क्या करें कमेंट में
करते हैं सर की टाइमिंग गलत हो सकती है और
दूसरा आप लोग बोलते हो कि सर कि सेशन तो
सिक्स मंथ तक चल जाएंगे ऐसे कोर्स के आप
डेली सेशन लीजिए डेली सेशन में मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं कि मेरे कोर्स पे जो व्यूज
आते हैं अभी तीन दिन में जाकर किसी पर न
के बनते हैं वह भी नहीं आएंगे 500 व्यू
मैक्स ल् ओल्ड स्टूडेंट तो ज्यादा आए नहीं
मेरे क्लाउड फेयर करना है बहुत हार्ड
है
आयुष तो डोंट ट्राई इट लगा हुआ है तो उसके
लिए अदर टेक्निक्स ढूंढनी पड़ेंगी आपको या
और तरीके ढूंढने पड़ेंगे आपको वह एडवांस
लेवल की बात है तो अभी बेसिक लेवल पर उन
पर ना ही बात करें तो सही
रहेगा बताइए अभी किसकी गलती
है आप लोग बताइए चैट में
मैं तो आप लोगों के लिए पहले से ही प्लान
करके बैठा हूं कि और भी फरदर जब सिस्टम
हैकिंग पढ़ने वाले हैं दो या तीन सेशन के
बाद हम
टेक्निक क्लास इफ यू वांट टू स्टडी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी देन फॉलो द
सीरीज दिस इज फ्रॉम जीरो टू इंटरमीडिएट
तो काली
[संगीत]
फंडामेंटल्स क्लियर करने के लिए अभी बात
रही आपकी साइबर सिक्योरिटी की तो दिस इज द
बेस्ट प्लेस या दिस इज द बेस्ट कोर्स जो
अभी चल रहा है अ ये कोर्स में अभी क्या है
कि हमने अपने जो बेसिक स्टेप्स थे वो क
कंप्लीट कर लिए हैं बस दो क्लासे जो बच गई
है न्यूमरेशन की दो या तीन क्लासेस मैक्स
की उसके बाद हम स्टार्ट करेंगे सिस्टम
हैकिंग के ऊपर वहां पर हम डायरेक्टली
लैब्स और पेन टेस्टिंग करेंगे कंप्लीट फुल
प्रैक्टिकल्स रहेगा जहां पर जरूरत है वहां
पर आई विल एक्सप्लेन फंडामेंटल्स बट टोटली
प्रैक्टिकल्स रहेगा और काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
सेशंस है
भी और फॉर योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन सबसे मैं
आपको बता देता हूं हमारे डे फोनिक साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन की एक प्री बुकिंग
स्टार्ट हो चुकी है तो आप क्या कर सकते हो
डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी की वेबसाइट को विजिट
कीजिए जिसको
अगर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेटर बनना है गो टू
योर डीसीसीआई
एंड दे वन बैच ओके अकैडमी
एंड
कोर्सेज वेट वेट वेट उसका एक लिंक है मेरे
पास फक्ड कॉ डीसीसीआई
टीसीसीआई ओके आप इसको विजिट कर सकते हो
यहां पर अपना ट्रेनिंग मटेरियल सकते हो
सिलेबस डाउनलोड कर सकते हो देख सकते हो
प्री बुकिंग स्टार्ट है और कुछ भी आपको
हेल्प चाहिए कोई भी गाइडेंस चाहिए आपकी
कोई भी क्यूरी आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां पर
पूछ सकते हो हेल्प सेक्शन में जाकर और
यहां पर आप चैट सेक्शन में पूछ सकते हो और
अदर वाइज हमारा जो मोबाइल्स यहां पर मेंशन
रहता मोबाइल नंबर आप यहां पर यह रहा इस पर
ट मैसेज कर सकते हो ईमेल कर सकते हो वहां
पर आपको आपका केरी से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल जाएगी तो आप क्या कर सकते हो इधर
अभी डे फोनिक्स सर्टिफाइड साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन पर जाकर एनरोल कर सकते हो
अगर आपको साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेटर बनना
है तो इसकी प्री बुकिंग ऑलरेडी ओपन है
यहां पर सब कुछ क्यूरी आपको मिल जाएगी और
आपको अनाउंसमेंट में भी आपको बताया गया कि
व्हाट विल बी द फीस और व्ट विल जो भी
चीजें आपको बताई गई हुई है
ओके तो क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं फिर
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे
हम तो जो भी नए स्टूडेंट्स हैं उनके लिए
बता देते हैं जो भी हम पीपीटी का यूज करते
हैं अपनी क्लासेस के अंदर आप चाहो तो क्या
कर सकते हो व पीपीटी आपको चाहिए और साथ
में डीई सर्टिफिकेट चाहिए डेनिक्स एथिकल
हैकर एसेंशियल सर्टिफिकेट चाहिए आपको तो
आपको सिंपली क्या करना है गो टू डेक्ड कॉम
अकेडमी टैब गो टू फ्री रिसोर्सेस
एंड डीई एई सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स एंड
रिसोर्सेस पे ₹ एंड 41 नरोल नाउ जो भी
रिसोर्सेस है जो भी नोट्स आपको यहां पर
मिल जाएंगे और फर्द जो हमारा प्लान है हम
प्लानिंग कर रहे हैं आप लोगों के लिए कि
हम जो लाइव ग मीट पर आपकी लाइव क्लासेस
इसलिए जो इनको इनरोल करते हैं ऑलरेडी 150
प्लस स्टूडेंट्स हैं तो वो लाइव क्लासेस
अटेंड कर पाएंगे
तो दूसरा क्या कर सकते हो आप कि आपको
सिंपली जो हमारे
youtube3 था क्लिक हियर एंड कोई भी अपडेट
चाहिए आपको रिलेटेड टू द क्लास की नेक्स्ट
क्लास कब होगी और टॉपिक क्या होगा या फर्द
कोई भी अनाउंसमेंट बग बाउंट की क्लास कब
आएगी सारी की सारी चीजें आपको अगर अपडेट
रखनी है तो आपको सिंपली जवाइन आवर
लिंक दिन का पेज है डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी अकेडमी का तो यहां पर भी आप
क्या कर सकते हो इसको फॉलो कर सकते हो और
जो भी आपको हम टास्क देते हैं तो टास्क को
आप क्या कर सकते हो डेफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी
को क्या कर सकते हो टैग कर सकते हो तो दज
आर द सम इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन जो आप
लोगों के लिए थी और अभी हम सेशन को
कंटिन्यू करते
हैं तो काफी टाइम हो गया छोटा सेशन है
बड़ा सेशन नहीं होगा तो आज भी 35 स्टूडेंट
ही है और पहले भी स्टूडेंट ही थी तो
टाइमिंग फिर से हम रिवाइज करेंगे और जो
पहले वाले टाइमिंग है उसी टाइमिंग प हम
शिफ्ट करेंगे क्लासेस उसी टाइमिंग पर
लेंगे क्योंकि मुझे नहीं लगता कि टाइमिंग
दि द बेस्ट टाइमिंग दे ओनली 30 स्टूडेंट्स
क्योंकि एक बहाना है क्लास में ना आने का
कि सर टाइमिंग शिफ्ट कर लो वो कर लो
क्योंकि वहां पर जब हमने
आपकी वोटिंग देखी थी तो 230 या 260 प्लस
वोटिंग उसमें थी और थ वोटिंग उसमें थी तो
यहां पर कोई भी नहीं
तो अभी यहां पर डीसी जेएसपी लिखा आ रहा है
तो मैंने अपनी स्लाइड अपडेट नहीं की थी आई
एम सॉरी फॉर दैट दिस कोर्स नेम इज डीई एच
जो हमने रिवाइज कर दिया था इस नेम से
क्योंकि यह कंफ्यूजन क्रिएट कर रहा था
स्टूडेंट्स के बीच में तो यहां पर जल्दी
आपको पीपीटी के अंदर नाम दूसरा मिलेगा डी
ई एच ई डे फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स
ओके तो अभी हम बात करते हैं एफटीपी
एन्यूमरेशन दे 28 स्टूडेंट्स ओनली या अभी
मैं टोटली डी मोटिवेट कर देते हो
यार नहीं मन करता पढ़ाने का
ऐसे तो कोई नहीं है तो अभी मैं इस पर
डिसीजन
लूंगा कि दे 20 या 30 स्टूडेंट्स इस पर
डिसीजन लेते हैं हम मैं और नितेश सर क्या
करना अगर बैच को क्लोज करना तो वी विल
क्लोज इट और इसी को हम पेड बैच निकालेंगे
डेली क्लास
लेंगे एक दिन छोड़ के एक दिन या सैटरडे
संडे हम क्लासेस लेंगे वेरी लो अमाउंट में
जिनको आना है वह भी जवाइन कर सकते हैं फिर
वो तो आएंगे डेफिनेटली दे 35 या 34
स्टूडेंट्स होते हैं जो डेली बेसिस पर
क्लासेस को अटेंड करते हैं तो वह तो आएंगे
मुझे पता है मैं एक मिनिमम अमाउंट पेमेंट
भी रखूंगा ना तो उनको उसकी जरूरत है व
इसके लिए आएंगे तो आई विल डिसाइड अभी आप
लोगों का जो फ्रीक्वेंसी है हमारे साथ आने
की 31
वेरी गुड अच्छा मोटिवेट कर रहे हो आप तो
एफटीपी एमेशन के बारे में बात करते हैं हम
सेशन को
अभी ज्यादा मैं आपको लिए बोरिंग नहीं
करूंगा तो एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन में हम सीखने
वाले हैं एफटीपी और एसएसएस के बारे में तो
एफटीपी होता क्या है फाइल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल इज स्टैंडर्ड नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल
ट यूज टीसीपी पोर्ट 21 एंड इज यूज टू
ट्रांसफर फाइल बिटवीन ए सर्वर एंड
क्लाइंट्स ओवर ए टीसीपी आईपी नेटवर्क सच
एज इंटरनेट बेसिकली क्या है एफटीपी क्या
होता है फाइल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल यह क्या
करता है पोर्ट नंबर 21 का यूज करता है
फाइल को ट्रांसफर करने के लिए टीसीपी आईपी
नेटवर्क के ऊपर मतलब इंटरनेट के ऊपर एटीपी
ऑपरेट्स इन ए क्लाइंट सर्वर मॉड्यूल
बेसिकली क्या है क्लाइंट और सर्वर का जो
मॉड्यूस होती है जो आर्केट है उसी फॉर्म
में क्या करता है ये ऑपरेट करता है मतलब
एक सर्वर होता है बाकी क्लाइंट्स होते हैं
जिस तरीके से सर्वर और क्लाइंट का
कम्युनिकेशन होता है उसी तरीके से एफटीपी
का भी कम्युनिकेशन होता है तो द क्लाइंट
इज ए प्रोग्राम ऑन योर कंप्यूटर दैट
इंटरेक्ट विद द सर्वर वेयर द फाइल्स आर
स्टोर्ड बेसिकली क्लाइंट एक ऐसा प्रोग्राम
होता है जो आपके सर्वर के साथ इंटरेक्ट
करता है जहां पर आपकी सारी की सारी फाइल
स्टोर्ड होती है
सेंट्रलाइज एफटीपी अलाउ यूजर टू अपलोड
डिलीट डिलीट डाउनलोड रिनेम मूव एंड कॉपी
फाइल्स ऑन द सर्वर किसी भी सर्वर के ऊपर
फाइल को अपलोड करने के लिए डाउनलोड करने
के लिए डिलीट करने के लिए रिनेम करने के
लिए या मूव करने के लिए हम एफटीपी का यूज
करते हैं इट इज आल्सो फ्रीक्वेंसी
ऑफ वेब सर्वर फॉर एग्जांपल इफ एनी वन एवर
बोट ए डोमेन नेम एंड सेट अप ए वेबसाइट देन
यू कैन यूटिलाइज एफटीपी टू ट्रांसफर योर
वेबसाइट फाइल्स टू द सर्वर एंड वॉइस वर्सा
अभी क्या होता है कभी किसी डोमेन वोट किया
होगा तो वहां पर आपको दो ऑप्शन मिलते हैं
या तो आपको जो डोमेन अथॉरिटी होस्टिंग
कंपनी है आपको सी पैनल का एक्सेस प्रोवाइड
कर देती है दूसरा आपको या आपको एफटीपी के
क्रेडेंशियल प्रोवाइड करते हैं आपकी वेब
साइट की जो पेजेस है या जो भी फाइल्स है
उसको अपलोड करने के लिए सर्वर के ऊपर अपने
होस्टिंग सर्वर के ऊपर अपलोड करने के लिए
तो उन केस में भी आपको क्या है एफटीपी
देखने को मिल जाता है सो इन ऑर्डर फॉर यू
टू डू दिस यू विल नीड टू ऑथेंटिकेट टू द
एफटीपी सर्वर एंड आफ्टर सक्सेसफुल
ऑथेंटिकेशन देन ओनली यू कैन डाउनलोड और
अपलोड फाइल्स फ्रॉम दैट पर्टिकुलर
डायरेक्टली बेसिकली एफटीपी भी क्या करता
है ऑथेंटिकेशन का यूज करता है फाइल को
अपलोड और डाउनलोड करने के लिए एक
पर्टिकुलर डायरेक्टरी से नेक्स्ट स्लाइड
पर चलते हैं वी कैन यूज मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स
टू नमरे इंफॉर्मेशन एज वेल एज परफॉर्म
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक्स ऑन टारगेट दैट इज
रनिंग एन एफटीपी सर्वर बेसिकली क्या कर
सकते हैं हम जो टारगेट आपका जो टारगेट है
अगर वो एफटीपी सर्वर रन कर रहा है तो उस
परे इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करने के लिए आप क्या
करते हो ब्रूट फोर्स टेक्निक का यूज करते
हो
ओके एफटीपी ऑथेंटिकेशन यूटिलाइज ए यूजर
नेम एंड पासवर्ड कॉमिनेशन बिफोर एक्सेस द
सर्वर एंड इट्स फाइल्स यह मैं आपको बता
चुका हूं इन सम केसेस एन इंप्रोपर्ली
कन्फर्टी पी सर्वर कैन बी लगड इन टू
एनोनिमस अगर आपका एफटीपी सर्वर सही से
कंफिल नहीं किया गया है उसको इंप्रोपर्ली
कन्फर किया गया है तो उस केस में क्या कर
सकते हो बिना पासवर्ड के क्या कर सकते हो
आप लॉग इन कर सकते हो जिसको हम बोल सकते
हैं एनोनिमस यूजर तो एनोनिमस एफटीपी अलाउ
यूजर टू लॉग इन विद ए जेनरिक यूजर नेम
लाइक एनोनिमस विदाउट ए पासवर्ड जहां पर आप
क्या कर सकते यूजर नेम में मेंशन करते हो
एनोनिमस और वहां पर पासवर्ड आप कोई भी
पासवर्ड रैंडम पासवर्ड इंसर्ट कर सकते हो
या क्या कर सकते हो आप उसको ब्लैंक छोड़
सकते हो और आप सक्सेसफुली एफटीपी सर्वर के
अंदर एंटर कर जाओगे तो अगर कोई एफटीपी
सर्वर मिस कन्फर हो तो आपको यह चीज देखने
को मिलेंगी अदर वाइज रेयर केस होगा आपको
एनोनिमस लॉगिन यूजर अलाउड मिलेगा या कंफिल
रियल सिनेरियो में अब अगर आपको एफटीपी
सर्वर वहां पर इनेबल मिलता है तो आप बेसिक
नॉर्मली आप क्या करते हो ब्रूट फोर्स
टेक्निक का यूज करते हो चाहे वो मेटा
स्लेट कंसोल के थ्रू करो एन मैप के थ्रू
करो या चाहे आप हाइड्रा के थ्रू करो ओके
तो बेसिकली और ब्रूट फोर्स आपका सक्सेसफुल
होगा या नहीं होगा यह डिपेंड करता आपकी
वर्ड लिस्ट के ऊपर य आपकी कित कितनी अच्छी
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हुई है यह कितनी अच्छी
आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट है तो एफटीपी के बारे में
सबको क्लियर है
बिल्कुल यह कोर्स बिल्कुल बिगनर के लिए है
इसमें एक भी ऐसा टॉपिक अभी तक नहीं आया जो
एडवांस लेवल का है क्योंकि एडवांस लेवल
कोर्स में यह बातें नहीं होती
यस जोन यह बिगनर लेवल के लिए
आने वाली क्लासेस में सीख लोगे आप पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग कैसे
करोगे यार क्यों स्पैमिंग कर रहे हो ग्रुप
में अभी मैं चैट को देखता ही नहीं हूं चलो
हम एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन का प्रैक्टिकल करते
हैं तो आई विल गो टू माय मशीन
तो अभी मैं क्या करर पैरेट ओस का यूज करने
वाला हूं प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करने के लिए
एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करने के लिए
बेसिकली उसके बाद हम एसएसए की बात करेंगे
जो हमारे दो मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक है तो
सबको स्क्रीन विजिबल है बताइए एक बार सबको
फंट साइज विजिबल
है तो आज का मेरा है मेरा नक् मशीन एक नटू
की एक लिनक्स मशीन है सेम अभी भी हम उसी
मशीन को यूज कर रहे हैं फॉर प्रैक्टिसेस
के लिए और अपकमिंग टाइम में हम मशीने चेंज
करेंगे तो सबसे पहले मैं पिंग करके पिंग
करता हूं कि जो मेरी मशीन है वह अप भी है
या नहीं है टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
19216811 ओके एंड हिट एंटर तो मेरी मशीन
अप एंड रनिंग कंडीशन में है मतलब एक्टिव
है ओके अभी हम क्या कर सबसे पहले यह फाइंड
आउट करते हैं कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स ओपन है
मेरी मशीन के ऊपर लेकिन मैं क्या करता हूं
अभी एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन कर रहा हूं तो मतलब
मैं क्या ओनली एफटीपी के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करूंगा तो कैसे ए मैप
हाइन सर्विस वर्जन देन उसके बाद हाइन प
पोर्ट नंबर 21 उसके बाद हाइन
ओ ओस फिंगरप्रिंटिंग देन आईपी एड्रेस
19216801 यह टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस और हिट
एंटर करते हैं आपको जल्दी इंफॉर्मेशन
देखने को
मिलेगी ओके तो यहां पर आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है दिस अ पोर्ट नंबर 21 मैं जैसे आपको
बताया था ओपन एटीपी प्रो
एटीपीडी
1.3.5 इसका वर्जन है दिस इज वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन दिस इज द मैक
एड्रेस ऑफ द डिवाइस एंड दिस इज ए
जब भी हम मेटा स्लट फ्रेमवर्क को यूज करते
हैं तो उससे पहले हमें क्या है पोस्ट
ग्रीस एसक्यूएल सर्वर को क्या करना उसके
सर्विस को स्टार्ट करना पड़ता है सिस्टम
सीटीएल सिस्टम सीटीएल
स्टार्ट पोस्ट ग्री
एस्कल यस सिस्टम सीटीएल सिस्टम सीटीएल की
स्पेलिंग रंग
थी ओके सर्विस हमारी स्टार्ट होगी सर्विस
को स्टेटस चेक कर लेते हैं एक बार
ओके सर्विस मेरी एक्टिव है अब मैं क्या
करता हूं मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क को स्टार्ट
करता
कंसोल ओके इट विल टेक टाइम फ्यू मिनट
अभी मैट स्प्लिट फेमर को स्टार्ट होने
देते हैं
ओके और आप सबको मैंने पहले लास्ट क्लासेस
बताया था जब भी हम एटा स्लेड फ्रेमवर्क को
यूज़ करते हैं तो किसी भी काम को परफॉर्म
करने के लिए कोई भी असेसमेंट परफॉर्म करने
के लिए हमें क्या करना है एक वर्क स्पेस
क्रिएट कर लेना है सो दैट कि आपका ट्रैक
रिकॉर्ड रहे सो दैट आपके पास वो
इंफॉर्मेशन अलग-अलग तरीके से रहे कि सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन मर्ज ना हो जाए एक साथ ना हो
जाए जिससे आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओ तो अभी मैं
वर्क जो स्पेस है क्रिएट करने वाला नहीं
हूं जस्ट आपको बताने वाला हूं कि एफटीपी
एन्यूमरेशन कैसे परफॉर्म करते हैं ओके तो
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं इसके लिए एक
मॉड्यूल होता है हमारा
सर्च हम सर्च करते हैं सबसे पहले अभी एक
मॉड्यूल हमारा अभी आप चाहो तो पोट
स्कैनिंग इससे भी कर सकते हो लेकिन मैं
आपको परफॉर्म करके नहीं दिखाऊंगा एफटीपी
सर्च एफटीपी अभी एफटीपी से रिलेटेड 493
अभी ये मिक्स है जिसमें ऑक्सल मॉडल्स भी
है एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल भी है तो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूस भी है तो अभी मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं
सर्च टाइप ऑक्सल
ऑक्सल नेम
एफटीपी यह रहा अभी दे टोटल 45 देखिए यहां
पर कौन कन सा
है अभी मैं इसको थोड़ा सा जूम आउट कर देता
हूं सोट आपको क्लियर लिस्ट दिखाई दे ओके
एंड फिर से हम इसको सर्च करेंगे यर एंड
एंड एंड य रहा यह रहा ओके
देखो विंडो य डस मॉडल है हमें स्कनर देखो
एफटीपी एडमिन पासवर्ड देन एफटीपी दे लॉट
ऑफ सोलर एफटीपी यूजर्स क्लाइंट एफटीपी दे
फजर है य फजिंग करने के लिए य स्कनर य रहा
नेट डिसीजन एफटीपी तो अभी हम क्या करने
वाले हैं फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं फाइंड आउट
करने वाला हूं कि कौन सा वर्जन हम यूज करर
अभी हम इसके लिए कौन सा यूज करेंगे यूज
ऑक्सल स्कनर यूज
ओके अभी हम देखते हैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
कौन सा हम यूज करने वाले हैं
एफटीपी यह रहा लरी स्कैनर एफटीपी वर्जन
मैं फाइंड आउट करना चाहता हूं कौन सा
वर्जन यूज हो रहा है तो यह अभी एक काम कर
देता अभी अभी यह
रहा यूज
15 यह रहा स्कैनर एफटीपी एफटीपी वर्जन स
ऑप्शन आप सबको पहले से पता है कैसे यूज
करते हैं मैं जस्ट आपको एफटीपी के केस में
कौन-कौन सी मॉडल्स का यूज किया जाता है
मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं बेसिकली देखो यहां
पर य आपको एफटीपी पासवर्ड सेट करने की
जरूरत नहीं है एफटीपी यूजर सेट करने की
जरूरत नहीं आर होस्ट मतलब आपका टारगेट
आईपी एड्रेस क्या है सेट आर होस्ट
19216801
व हिट एंटर हमने यहां पर टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस को सेट कर दिया है आर पोर्ट टारगेट
पोर्ट कौन सा 21 अब सिंपली हम इसको क्या
कर देंगे रन कर देंगे अगर आपको फिर से
देखना के बा शो ऑप्शंस करके देखते हैं कि
जो भी हमने सेट किया था वो हुआ या नहीं
हुआ देखो ये इंफॉर्मेशन सेट की थी सेट हो
गई है अभी आप क्या करते
एक्सप्लोइट एक्सप्लोइट हिट
एंटर तो इसने भी बैनर ग्रैबिंग करके आपको
बता दिया कि इट इज प्रो एफटीपीडी वन 3.5
सर्वर ओके तो सेम इंफॉर्मेशन जो हमने एन
मैप के थ्रू फाइंड आउट की
थी अभी हम चाहे तो क्या कर सकते ब्रूट
फोर्स कर सकते हैं तो ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म
करने के लिए अभी हम क्या करते हैं यह
रहा कि अभी ब फ परफॉर्म करके दिखाना या
नहीं दिखाना उसके लिए हम एक मॉड्यूल का
यूज करते हैं कौन सा मॉड्यूल होता है मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं
अभी य रहा दिस वन यह रहा एंड मॉड्यूल नेम
हैरा एफटीपी
लॉगिन वे द एफटीपी स्कनर एसस ओके
एफटीपी यह रहा लरी स्कैनर एफटीपी लॉग इन
सिंपली कॉपी या यूज
12 यूज नटू सिंपल है यूज करना और अभी 100
100 ऑप्शंस
हिट एंटर यहां पर देखिए आपको क्या करना
एनोनिमस लॉगिन फॉल्स है आप चाहो तो इसको
ट्राई यस कर सकते हो मतलब ट्रू कर सकते हो
अटेंप्ट टू लॉगिन विद ए ब्लैंक यूजर नेम
एंड पासवर्ड ब्लैंक पासवर्ड ओके ब्रूट
फॉर्स स्पीड बाय डिफॉल्ट रहने देते हैं यह
आपको सेट करने की जरूरत नहीं है आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है अगर आपके पास पासवर्ड
तो होगा नहीं आप ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म करने
वाले हो तो आपको यहां पर पास फाइल के अंदर
क्या मेंशन करना आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट कौन सी
जो भी आपके पास अवेलेबल हो जो आपने
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के दौरान बनाई है और
डोंट वरी आपको चिंता करने की बिल्कुल भी
जरूरत नहीं कि सर एफटीपी के थ्रू हम एंग
कैसे परफॉर्म करेंगे जल्द ही हम एफटीपी के
थ्रू भी सिस्टम में एक्सेस लेंगे ये चिंता
करने की जरूरत नहीं है ओके प्रॉक्सीस या
एफटीपी के थ्रू हमें किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है जिसका हम यूज करके
सिस्टम में घुस सकते हैं ओके अभी उसके बाद
आर रोस्ट आपको ये सेट करना पड़ेगा देन
उसके बाद आर पोट ऑलरेडी सेट है और नंबर ऑफ
थ्रेड्स आप चाहो तो अपनी मशीन की कॉन्फिन
के अकॉर्डिंग सेट कर सकते हो आपको यूजर
पास फाइल नहीं यह आपको जरूरत नहीं है और
आपको यूजर फाइल इसमें आपको वर्डलिस्ट
मेंशन करनी है जहां पर यूजर नेम रहेगा
उसके बाद सिंपली आपको रन कर देना है तो यह
सब लोग खुद से कर लोगे अगर जब इसको रन
करोगे मेरे केस में जो है यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड क्या है
वेग्रो कर क्योंकि इट विल टेक टाइम अराउंड
हाफ एन आवर इट विल टेक तो मैं आप लोगों का
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करना चाहता ना ही अपना
टाइम वेस्ट करना चाहता ओके ट्स व्हाई आप
चाहो तो उसको खुद से परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
कर
लोगे बताइए यस या नो
तो एक काम कीजिए आप देखो आप बिगनर फेस में
होते हैं शुभम तो आपको सिंपली अभी दे
प्रैक्टिस किया जो हमने यूज कर लिया उसकी
एक चीट शट होती है या आप जब भी ग करोगे तो
आप उसके चीट शट निकालिए अभी सभी स्क्रिप्ट
यूज नहीं होती सभी की सभी स्क्रिप्ट यूज
नहीं होती एज पर रिक्वायरमेंट होती है तो
जो मोस्ट पॉपुलर चीटशीट होती है एफटीपी के
केस में वह आप अपने पास नोट डाउन करके
रखिए मैं हमेशा अपनी क्लास में यही बताता
हूं कि जब भी कोई आपको पढ़ाता मैं आपको
क्या करता हूं कि मैक्सिमम जो आपके चीट
शीट अवेलेबल है ना ग पे जो भी चीट शीट है
जो भी वो स्क्रिप्ट यूज करते हैं जो भी वो
मॉड्यूस यूज करते हैं या मोस्ट कॉमन जो
यूज किए जाते हैं बाकी के जिनको टच भी
नहीं किया जाता वोह सारे के सारे मैं अपनी
क्लास में परफॉर्म करके दिखाता हूं तो आप
इनकी चीट शट बना के रखिए ओ आप इनकी चीट ट
बना के रखिए आपके काफी काम आएगी
चाहो तो आप चैट जीपीटी भी कर सकते हो
अभी आपको सर्च करने की जरूरत नहीं मैं
आपको बताता रहूं यार की अभी मैं पूरी की
पूरी चीट शट आपको करवाता हूं मैं मोस्ट
कॉमन जो चीट शीट होती है उनकी मैक्सिमम
चीजें मैं आपको करवाता हूं प्रैक्टिकली
अदर वाइज में इतना टाइम देने की जरूरत ही
नहीं थी बाकी लोगों की
तरह ओके तो यह आप लोग खुद से ट्राई कीजिए
इसको लॉगिन लॉगिन को और ब्रूट फोर्स
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो आप अभी मैं चलता हूं
नेक्स्ट आप एक और चीज चेक कर सकते हो इसके
अंदर कि जो मेरी यह मशीन है इस ये जो मैं
आपने बताया था ना कि यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड
की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है या आप अगर मिस
कन्फर होगी तो आप क्या एनोनिमस उसके अंदर
लॉगिन कर सकते उसके लिए भी एक मॉड्यूल
होता है फाइंड आउट करते हैं कि यह चेक
करने के लिए क्या मैं इसके अंदर
एनोनिमस क्या कर सकता हूं एंटर कर सकता
हूं नहीं कर सकता तो देखिए यह
रहा स्क्रिप्ट
एटीपी एनोनिमस होगा
एफटीपी एफटीपी नहीं ओली स्कैनर
एफटीपी ओके ओके
ओके चलो मेरे पास उसका नाम है मिल जाएगा
यह भी तो अगर हम सर्च करेंगे तो मिल जाएगा
तो अभी यूज करते हैं लरी
ऑक्सल ऑक्ल
स्कैनर उसके बाद
एफटीपी उसके बाद
एनोनिमस एनोनिमस हिट एंटर हमने यूज कर
लिया शो
ऑप्शन शो ऑप्शंस यह रहा अभी अगर आप इस
स्क्रिप्ट के बारे में जानना चाहते हो या
इस मॉड्यूस के बारे में जानना चाहते हो कि
मॉड्यूल करता क्या है तो सिंपली आपको क्या
करना है
शो इंफो हिट एंटर यह देखिए डिटेक्ट
एनोनिमस एफटीपी सर्वर एक्सेस ओनली यही काम
करता ओके अ भी देखो एफटीपी पासवर्ड यह
यूजर नेम इन्होंने बाय डिफॉल्ट सेट किया
हुआ है आर होस्ट य चेक करेगा तो मुझे
सिर्फ सेट आर होस्ट चेक करना ओके
सेट आर होस्ट
192.168
181 यह रहा हिट एंटर और उसके बाद हम क्या
करते सीधा एक्सट कर देते हैं और यह आपको
बता
देगा कि आप इसके अंदर एफटीपी के अंदर
एनोनिमस लॉग इन कर सकते हैं या नहीं कर
सकते ओके स्कैन किया बट इसने कुछ भी आपको
नहीं बताया मतलब आप एनोनिमस लॉग इन नहीं
कर सकते दूसरा तरीका क्या होता है मैं
आपको बता देता हूं
आप एन मैप के थ्रू भी कर सता अभी मैं इसको
क्या कर देता हूं एग्जिट कर देता हूं तो
इसकी यह दो तीन स्क्रिप्ट ही आपको अभी याद
रखने की जरूरत है इसके लिए बिगनर लेवल
पर ज्यादा अभी अपने आपको को वो नहीं करना
है कि कहते हैं कि क्या बोलते हैं आप बोल
सकते हो खुद को बर्न आउट बोल सकते हो कि
मतलब इतना कंफ्यूज नहीं करना है कि सर
इतनी स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल कौन सी यूज करो
अभी के लिए उतनी करो जितनी आपको कोई भी
सिखाता उसकी एक चीट चट बनाइए जैसे जैसे
आपको पास आपके पास एक्सपीरियंस होगा जैसे
जैसे आप जितनी ज्यादा प्रैक्टिस करोगे
उतनी ज्यादा आपके पास नॉलेज होगी और आपके
एक्सपीरियंस के बेस पर आपको पता होगा कि
कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट आपके लिए यूजफुल है कौन
सी स्क्रिप्ट नॉट यूजफुल और यह जो एमएसएफ
के थ्रू आपको मैंने बताया य एक ऑटोमेटिक
वे ही है इसमें कहीं पर भी आपने मैनुअल
कुछ भी नहीं
किया ओके अभी अब मैं ट्राई करता हूं अभी
किसके
थ्रू एफटीपी के थ्रू देखो एक तरीका होता
है एफटीपी के अंदर एक तो चेक कर सकते हो
आप पहले ए मैप के थ्रू तो ए
मैप उसके बाद हम चेक कर सकते
हैं ए मैप उसके बाद हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट इक्वल साइन
एफटीपी उसके बाद आप क्या कर सकते
हो स्टार लगा सकते हो मतलब जितनी भी
एफटीपी की जितनी भी स्क्रिप्ट है एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट है सारी की सारी आप अप्लाई कर
दीजिए और मुझे टारगेट के ऊपर क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है वो हम देखते हैं चाहे
व ब्रूट फोर्स स्क्रिप्ट हो चाहे आपकी वह
एनोनिमस स्क्रिप्ट हो जो भी स्क्रिप्ट
अवेलेबल है एफटीपी से रिलेटेड सारी सारी
परफॉर्म कर इट विल टेक टाइम देन उसके बाद
हम एसवी यूज भी करते हैं इसके सर्विस
वर्जन हाइन पोर्ट 21 देन उसके बाद यह हो
गया टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस इसके बाद हम क्या
करेंगे टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस
19216811 हिट एंटर
होस्ट डाउन मतलब य मशीन बंद हो
गई नाउ फिर से मेरी मशीन अप है पिंग करते
हैं हम एक बार
192.16
0.11 ट एंटर
ओके डॉट ओके माय मशीन इज
अप सिखा देंगे शिवराज पर अभी
नहीं टाइम का थोड़ा वेट कीजिए हर चीज हम
ट्राई करेंगे ब्रूट फोर्स भी करेंगे
डायरेक्टरी अटैक ट्रैवर्सल अटैक भी करेंगे
तो सारी चीजें करेंगे आरसी भी करेंगे
कमांड इजेक्शन भी करेंगे बट इट विल टेक
टाइम आपके पास टाइम नहीं है तो आप क्लास
छोड़कर जा सकते
हैं ओके अभी मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से रन
करते हैं यह रहा एन मैप स्क्रिप्ट एप
सर्विस वर्जन पोट 21 181 यह
रहा इट विल टेक टाइम और यह आपको बता देगा
कि आप एनोनिमस इसमें लॉगिन कर सकते हो या
नहीं कर सकते हो जो भी इंपॉर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन रिलेटेड टू एफटीपी आपको यह बता
देगा या एक पर्टिकुलर स्क्रिप्ट होती है
एफटीपी हाफ एनन जो यह चेक करती है कि आप
इस एफटीपी सर्वर के अंदर एनोनिमस लॉग इन
कर सकते हो या नहीं कर सकते हो या अगर आप
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो
एन मैप के थ्रू तो एक स्क्रिप्ट होती
है एफटीपी हाइन ब्रूट एफटीपी हाइ फन ब्रूट
देन आर्गुमेंट में आपको ऐड करना पड़ेगा
पासवर्ड लिस्ट या व पासवर्ड और आपकी जो
बोलते हैं वर्ड लिस्ट पासवर्ड वर्ड लिस्ट
और यूजर नेम वर्ड लिस्ट दोनों दोनों आपको
ऐड करनी पड़ेगी तो आपका जो एन मैप है वो
भी ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई कर सकता है तीसरी
चीज क्या आप हाइड्रा के थ्रू भी कर सकते
हो और जो हमारी पहली लैब रहेगी या पहली या
दूसरी लैब रहेगी उसमें हम एफटीपी के थ्रू
इन के थ्रू हम क्या करेंगे सिस्टम में
घुसने की कोशिश करेंगे जहां पर हम हाइड्रा
का यूज करेंगे तो हाइड्रा को अभी यूज करना
मैं आपको सिखा नहीं रहा क्योंकि वहां पर
हाइड्रा को एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कि हाइड्रा
को यूज कैसे करते हैं हाइड्रा का काम क्या
है और हाइड्रा क्या है तो वह मैं आपको बाद
में बताऊंगा सिस्टम हैकिंग जैसे हम
स्टार्ट कर करने वाले तीन क्लास ओनली थ्री
क्लास उसके बाद हम सिस्टम हैकिंग स्टार्ट
करेंगे और अभी जो मैं बात कर रहा था ग मीट
के थ्रू अगर इतने स्टूडेंट्स है तो आई विल
नोट टेक ऑन द क्लासेस ऑन द ग मीट आई विल
डिलीवर ऑन दय स्ट्रीम अदर वाइज तो मैं अभी
बंद ही करने वाला हूं बेसिकली
तो इट विल टेक टाइम 70 पर इज डन देन उसके
बाद नेक्स्ट टॉपिक हमारा रहेगा एसएसएस
बिल्कुल क्योंकि देखो एफटीपी और एसएसएस
में ज्यादा कुछ है नहीं यूज करने के लिए
क्योंकि यह एक ऐसी सर्विसेस है जहां पर
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा या तो ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक ट्राई करना पड़ेगा इ इंफॉर्मेशन लेने
के लिए सिस्टम के अंदर जाने के लिए एसएसएस
में क्या है एसएसएस में एक तो ब्रुड फोर्स
ट्राई कर सकते हो या आपके पास की होनी
चाहिए तभी आप उसके बारे में ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन या उसका यूज कर सकते हो
तो ये ऐसी सर्विसेस है यहां पर आपके पास
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन होगी या इंपोर्टेंट
वर्ड लिस्ट होगी तभी आप आगे बढ़ सकते हो
जैसे नेट बायस और एसएमबी के केस में क्या
था जो मैंने आपको बताया उसमें आप ट्राई भी
कर सकते थे ब्रूट फोर्स तो क्या कि लास्ट
ऑप्शन आता था और भी ज्यादा डिटेल
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए लेकिन ओपन सर्विसेस के
बेस पे भी आपको इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती थी
लेकिन यह सर्विसेस ऐसी है एफटीपी और एसएसए
यहां पर क्या है कि आपको सिस्टम के अंदर
जाने के लिए क्योंकि सर्वर और क्लाइंट का
आर्किटेक्चर है और एसएसए एक ऐसा
प्रोटोकॉल्स है अभी मैं आपको बताऊंगा जो
रिमोट एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करता है तो एक
सिक्योर प्रोटोकॉल्स है तो उसपे क्या
ज्यादा कुछ नहीं है उसपे या तो आप पता कर
सकते हो कि इसकी आपको की फाइंड आउट करनी
पड़ेगी या आपको ब्रूट फोर्स करना पड़ेगा
तभी जाके आप सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले सकते हो
या उस का वर्जन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
वर्जन के बेस पर वटी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
उस वटी के थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो एक्सेस
ले सकते हो सिर्फ इतना ही कर सकते हो इनों
के दोनों के केस में इससे ज्यादा आप नहीं
कर सकते इस इससे मतलब चाहे इसम कितनी भी
स्क्रिप्ट लगा लो इतना ही कर सकते
हो अभी थोड़ा सा समय लेगा यह
और एफटीपी में जब आप एक बार लॉग इन कर
लेते हो लॉग इन करने के बावजूद आप कैसे उस
फाइल को लिस्ट आउट कर सकते हो और कैसे
उनको अपलोड कर सकते हो डाउनलोड कर सकते हो
वह भी आप क्या है आपको मैं क्लासेस में
बताऊंगा क्योंकि हम परफॉर्म करने वाले सून
पहली क्लास सिस्टम हैकिंग की पहली क्लास
में नहीं करेंगे सिस्टम हैकिंग में भी मैं
आपको कुछ इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
करूंगा क्योंकि जो यहां पर बोलते हैं सर
कितना वेट करें हम उस क्लास का मुझे ये
चीज टास्क का हमसे वेट नहीं हो रहा तो भाई
ऐसी बात है कि मैं आपको मिसगाइड नहीं
करूंगा एक रोड मैप होता है एक तरीका होता
है पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का आप किसी भी एक
तरीके को या कहीं से आप क्या करोगे उसको
स्किप करोगे तो क्या होगा उस टाइम के लिए
आप सब आपका मतलब पूरा हो जाएगा लेकिन क्या
है कि वहां से आप मिसगाइड हो जाओगे और
पूरी पूरी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग होती है
आपकी वो खराब हो जाती है क्योंकि आप जब
किसी भी कंपनी के लिए हायर किए जाते हो तो
आपको ट्रस्ट किया जाता है कि आप उनकी
कंपनी को प्रोटेक्ट करोगे कोई भी कंपनी आप
पर ट्रस्ट करती है ऐसे रैंडम कोई भी कंपनी
किसी को नहीं उठाती जब कोई कंपनी आपको
ट्रस्ट करती है तो इट्स माय
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी या इट्स एवरी ट्रेनर
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी थी आपको हर चीज सिखाई जाए
एक अप्रोच वे में एक सही तरीके से ना कि
कि बस आपको जो चाहिए वह बताया जाए क्योंकि
जब यही प्रॉब्लम हो है कि जब हम मिस मतलब
मिस कर जाते कुछ चीजों को स्किप कर जाते
जिसकी वजह से हम कुछ ऐसी चीजें छोड़ देते
हैं सिस्टम के ऊपर या कुछ ऐसे स्टेप भूल
जाते हैं सिस्टम के ऊपर जो हम सोचेंगे यार
मैं मास्टर तो बन गया लेकिन यह बेसिक लेवल
की गलती कैसे मैंने कर दी ठीक है आप
एडवांस जाने के लिए आपको क्योंकि यह कोर्स
सिर्फ एक लेवल है एडवांस बहुत कुछ है
सीखने के लिए बहुत कुछ है एडवांस में आप
लोग लगता है कि मैं जस्ट सिंपल फंडामेंटल
स इस इंटरमीडिएट लेवल करके मैं बहुत कुछ
कर लूंगा तो आपकी गलतफहमी है या आपको जो
youtube0 हैं कि जस्ट यह करने से यह हो
जाएगा बहुत बड़ी गलतफहमी है ठीक है आप
बहुत बड़ी चीज है यह अपने आप में एडवांस
लेवल प्रोफेशनल लेवल अलग होते हैं जहां पर
आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने की जरूरत होती है
जस्ट टूल ही नहीं प्लस में मैनुअल
टेक्निक्स प्लस में आपके खुद की नॉलेज खुद
की डेवलपमेंट सारी चीजें होती है फिर वो
एक लेवल अलग होता है उसके लिए आपको
एक्सपीरियंस चाहिए होता है जूनियर से
सीनियर बनना पड़ता है तो व सारी चीजें
होती है तो आप को डिसाइड करना है कि आपको
एक गाइडेड वे में जाना है या आपको स्टेप
स्किप कर करके आगे बढ़ना है यह इट्स योर
चॉइस आप जैसे आगे बढ़ना चाहते हो आप बढ़
सकते हो मैं आपको नहीं रोक सकता अभी पता
नहीं टूल काम करना स्टेप कम कर दिया इसने
यहां पर हैंग हो गया आई डोंट नो तो अभी
तो पता नहीं अभी मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता
हूं तो आप इस तरीके से इसको यूज कर सकते
हो मैं अभी दूसरा तरीका बताता हूं ए मैप
हान एसवी सर्विस वर्जन हाइन प
21 और उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं देन हाइन
हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद एफटीपी अनन एक
स्क्रिप्ट होती है जो एनोनिमस चेक करने के
लिए 192.168
168.0 181 181 हिट
एंटर ना अभी इसने कुछ भी नहीं बताया मतलब
आपकी एनोनिमस अलाउ नहीं कुछ रिजल्ट आपको
प्रोवाइड करनी रहाय ओके तो प्लीज रिपोर्ट
एनी इनकरेक्ट डिटेल्स बस इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है यह स्क्रिप्ट भी
काम करके नहीं दिखा रहा है इधर तो अभी हम
क्या करते दूसरा तरीका क्या होता कि क्या
मैं एनोनिमस लॉगिन कर सकता हूं नहीं कर
सकता सिंपली आपको क्या करना है एफटीपी
एफटीपी को आप ऐसे यूज कर सकते हो एफटीपी
फॉलो बाय योर आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द टारगेट
मशीन
192.168 181 सिंपली हिट एंटर ये आपको नेम
पूछेगा तो एनोनिमस आप लिख सकते
हो एनोनिमस स्पेलिंग सही है ए एन ओ एन वाई
एम ओ यूएस मे बी इट्स राइट पासवर्ड एमटी
छोड़ दिया हिट ओके लॉग इन फील्ड मतलब क्या
है कि आप इसमें
एनोनिमस एक्सेस नहीं कर सकते अभी मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं भाई एग्जिट कर देता क्योंकि
आप इसको यूज ही नहीं कर पाओगे लॉगिन नहीं
कर पाए ओके दूसरा एक और चीज होती है
एफटीपी में अभी फॉर एग्जांपल मेरे पास
क्रेडेंशियल है मैंने ब्रूट फोर्स किया और
मेरे पास क्रेडेंशियल तो मैं कैसे लॉग इन
करूंगा
192 ड
168.0 181 हिट एंटर पी ए जीी आर ए एन टी
यह मेरा यूजर नेम है पासवर्ड पी ए जीी आर
ए एन टी वे ग्रेंट हिट एंटर सक्सेसफुली
मैंने क्या कि लिया इसके अंदर लॉगइन कर
लिया अभी मुझे नहीं पता एफटीपी को कैसे
यूज करना है तो सिंपली क्वेश्चन मार्क
इसकी हेल्प फाइल को आप देख सकते हो तो ये
सारी कमांड आप यूज कर सकते हो कि बाय के
सीडी एक डायरेक्टरी से दूसरी
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
मेरी क्या है होम वेगें तो मैं
सीडी बैक तो सक्सेसफुल अभी मैं क्या करता
हूं फिर से पीडब्ल्यूडी करता हूं यह रहा
यह होम फाइल के अंदर हूं फिर से सीडी ओके
या अभी मैं क्या करता हूं अभी यह रहा फिर
से पीडब्ल्यूडी बैक रूट डायरेक्टरी अभी
एलस करता हूं तो 29 एंटरिंग एक्सटेंड
पैसिव मोड मतलब अभी यहां पर कुछ आपको शो
नहीं कर रहा क्योंकि इसके अंदर या तो कुछ
फाइलें होंगी नहीं या शो नहीं कर रहा ये
दि यहां पर स्टक हो गया लेकिन यहां पर
डेफिनेटली इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलती
है अभी मैं इसको कंट्रोल सी करता हूं इधर
स्टॉप कर देता हूं कंट्रोल सी हो गया देन
और उसके आप क्या कर सकते अगर किसी फाइल को
आपने अपलोड क्या करना है डाउनलोड करना तो
इसके लिए भी इसमें अंदर ऑप्शन होता है एक
ऑप्शन होता आपका यह रहा गेट फाइल गेट का
यूज करोगे आप किसी भी फाइल को क्या कर
सकते हो डाउनलोड कर सकते हो इससे और अपलोड
करने के लिए भी एक कमांड होती है इसके
अंदर कहां कहां कहां यह रहा एफ गेट ओके
गेट हो गया इमेज एलसीडी एल
एस एम गेट मोर टाइम मोर
एक कमांड होती है इसी के अंदर मे भी अपलोड
करके होगी इसमें पुट पुट कमांड होगी एक
पुट आप क्या कर सते उसके अंदर अपलोड कर
सकते हो तो आप इस तरीके से एफटीपी को यूज
कर सकते हो और हम अपकमिंग क्लासेस में
इसको यूज करने वाले हैं डेफिनेटली जो
ज्यादा अभी हम ज्यादा दूर नहीं है अपने
टारगेट से धीरे धीरे अभी क्या हम
इंटरेस्टिंग बनाएंगे इन क्लासेस को और आगे
बढ़ेंगे
तो सबको एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन समझ में आया
एवरीवन प्रैक्टिकली और थरेट कली एफटीपी
होता क्या है कौन से पोर्ट का यूज करता है
और होस अभी कई केसेस में आपको एफटीपी का
पोर्ट भी दूसरा मिल सकता है अगर कन्फर
किया हुआ है तो आपको हमेशा क्या करना है
सर्वि वर्जन डिटेक्शन करते हुए सभी पोर्ट
की स्कैनिंग डेफिनेटली करनी है हो सकता 21
की जगह कोई ऐसा पोर्ट यूज किया जा रहा हो
जिस पर आपका शक भी ना जाए तो हमेशा आपको
सभी पोर्ट को एक बार करना चाहिए तो यही
होती है एफटीपी एन्यूमरेशन सबको समझ में
आया एवरीवन गट
क्लियर
एवरीवन सभी चैट में मुझे बताएंगे
सभी के
सभी मुझे पासवर्ड इसलिए पता हुआ क्योंकि
मशीनस मैंने कन्फर की हुई है मशीनस मेरी
है तो इसलिए मुझे पासवर्ड का पता है अदर
वाइज क्या कि अगर आप ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई
करोगे उस ब्रूट फोर्स वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर
आप इन यह पासवर्ड दोनों अवेलेबल है आप
एफटीपी लॉगिन के थ्रू उसको क्रैक करने की
कोशिश कर तो हो जाएगा अगर आप लोगों को लैब
एक्सेस खुद का सेटअप करना चाहिए अदर वाइज
अभी तक किसी को अगर लैब का एक्सेस नहीं है
कोई लैग प हां मैंने आपको बताया था टास्क
में वन थिंग यह रहा यहां
पर ट्राई हैक
मी ट्राई हैक
मी यह रहा और मैंने आपको बताया था नेटली
आपको मैंने बताया हुआ है एक टास्क भी दिया
था किसी ने उसको अभी तक फुलफिल नहीं किया
किसी ने नहीं किया उस टास्क को किसीने
रिपोर्ट ही नहीं भेजी उसकी अभी मैं आप लोग
क्या बोलू इस चीज के लिए यह
रहा नेटवर्क सर्विसेस करके होगा
एक आने वाले टाइम में आपको जरूरत नहीं
पड़ेगी लैब सेटअप करने की क्योंकि मैं
आपको खुद से ही बताऊंगा आपको कौन से करने
चाहिए देखिए ये रहा नेटवर्क सर्विसेस और
शद एफटीपी अंडरस्टैंडिंग एफटीपी
एनरेटक सकते हो एफटीपी के थ्रू टास्क नंबर
ए टास्क नंबर नाइन टास्क नंबर
10 तीनों टास्क आप खुद से ट्राई कीजिए
यहां पर आप प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो य रहा
मैं आपको फिर से लिंक प्रोवाइड कर देता
हूं इस लैब का आप चाहो तो इस परे फिर से
कर सकते
हो यह
रहा तो जब बलड फोर्सिंग में सिंह हमेशा
डिपेंड करती है आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट आपके पास
परफेक्ट वर्ड लिस्ट है तो ही आप उसको
क्रैक कर सकते हो अदर वाइज नहीं कर सकते
यह है सच्चाई ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
की
ओके एनीथिंग किसी को कोई डाउट
है एसएसएस पर चले
पब्लिक आईपी प आप पहले देखिए ना कि आपको
मिल भी रहा है या कुछ नहीं मिल
रहा देखि अमन
सेख अभी नमरे पार्ट बाद में आता है पहले
आपका पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन अभी इन दोनों में आपके पास
क्या है इंफॉर्मेशन होती है आपके पास
टारगेट होता है कि मुझे अभी इसी टारगेट पर
क्या करना है स्कैनिंग परफॉर्म करनी है इस
टारगेट के बारे में ज्यादा से ज्यादा वटी
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करनी है टारगेट
के बारे में ज्यादा से ज्यादा ट्राई करना
है तब उस केस में आप एन्यूमरेशन करते हो
वहां पर आपके पास कौन-कौन से पोर्ट्स ओपन
है कौन सी सर्विस रन कर रहे होग पर्टिकुलर
सर्विस प आप क्या करते हो एन्यूमरेशन करते
हो
ओके ट फोर्स कैसे करें तो यह तो बहुत ही
अजीब सवाल है आपका लास्ट दो तीन क्लासेस
में मैंने हर बार ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई किया
है विद द हेल्प ऑफ एमएसएफ कंसोल और जो
बाकी और दूसरे तरीकों से मैं आने वाली
क्लासेस में साथ के साथ परफॉर्म करके
दिखाऊंगा लेकिन मैंने आपको बताया ब्रूट
फोर्स ट्राई करने के लिए अभी जस्ट
एक्सप्लेन किया था एफटीपी लॉगिन वाले
मॉड्यूस को जिसमें मैंने आपको बताया था
यहां पर आपको पासवर्ड वर्ड लिस्ट रखनी है
यहां पर यूजर वर्ड लिस्ट रखनी है और यहां
पर आपको आरओ सेट करना और एक्सप्लोइट कर
देना इट विल टेक टाम य आपको क्रैक करके दे
देगा परफेक्ट वर्डलिस्ट के लिए आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी होगी ज्यादा से
ज्यादा जितनी अच्छी आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन
होगी टारगेट के बारे में और जितनी ज्यादा
बाकी दूसरी क्या आपकी सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग भी काफी हेल्पफुल करती है फिर
आप
ओके तो इसलिए फेल हो जाता है क्योंकि आपकी
मशीन प्रोटेक्ट कर रही है विंडो फायर वाल
एक्टिवेट
है विंडो
डिफेंडर मयंक
डिफेंडर ऑन है
ना ऑफ थी वो तो एसएमबी आपके में सही से
काम कर रहा
है खुद की मशीन में आपने एसएमबी सेटअप
किया
था जल्दी से
बताइए तो फिर
फेल तो नहीं करना
चाहिए मेरा तो फेल नहीं किया था आप सबके
सामने मैंने विंडो पर परफॉर्म किया
था मेटा स्प्ले टेबल मशीन थी थी विंडोज की
सर्वर 2008 उसके ऊपर मैंने परफॉर्म किया
था एसएमबी शायद एसएमबी नेट ब में से किसी
एक पर मैंने ट्राई किया था और सक्सेसफुली
हमने एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर गग ट्राई किया था
नहीं हमारा तो फेल नहीं हुआ
था फिर से ट्राई कीए फेल नहीं
होगा कुछ और रीजन रहे कुछ और अदर
सिक्योरिटी कन्फेशन रही होंगी जिनकी वजह
से भी हो सकता है या आपकी मशीन में
प्रॉब्लम हो गई
होगी हा एफटीपी ल होती है जो आपको फाइंड
आउट करके देती है कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
तो आपने विंडो 8 पर ट्राई किया बट आप सही
से कन्फर नहीं कर पाए होगे आपका टूल सही
से उस परे आपने कोई ना कोई उसके ऑप्शन को
छोड़ दिया होगा मयंक फिर से ट्राई कि उसके
बारे में थोड़ा सा डिटेल रिसर्च करो उस
मॉड्यूल के बारे में आपने क्या गलती की
रिवाइज कीजिए
ओके य आपकी मशीन एक्सप्लोइट कर ग आपकी
मशीन जो उसको वो नहीं कर क्योंकि ब्रूट
फोर्स अटैक करने के लिए मशीन की काफी
रिसोर्सेस लगते
हैं या टेक्निकल क्लास आप इस तरीके से
बोले सर मैं दोनों आंखों से ब्लाइंड ह
100% हूं मैं फिर भी साइबर सिकटी स्टडी कर
रहा हूं प्लीज गाइड मी असिस्ट मी तो मैंने
आपको बताया ना कि डे वन से लेकर अभी तक
कीजिए इसमें कुछ भी नया नहीं है कुछ भी
ऐसा नहीं है
कि ऊपर से जा रहा हो एवरीथिंग इ हर एक चीज
डिटेल्स में है और आपने अगर कभी जिंदगी
में अगर कंप्यूटर के बारे में नहीं पता तो
मत जाइए फिर पहले आपको कंप्यूटर के
फंडामेंटल क्लियर कीजिए अपने लाइफ में कि
कंप्यूटर कैसे काम करता है कैसे उसको
चलाते हैं अगर आपको वही नॉलेज नहीं है तो
फिर आप नहीं कर
पाओगे अगर आपके पास पीसी की नॉलेज है तो
फिर आपका सवाल ही इरेलीवेंट है मुझे लग ही
नहीं रहा कि क्या पूछना चाह रहे आप
ओके चलो
एसएसए एन्यूमरेशन के बारे में बात करते
हैं ओके एसएसए होता क्या है जिसको हम
बोलते हैं सिक्योर सेल एसएस इज ए
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल यूज
फॉर सिक्योर एक्सेसिंग एंड मैनेजिंग
डिवाइस ओवर एन अनसिक्योर नेटवर्क अब ये
अनसिक्योर नेटवर्क क्या है कोई गेस कर
सकता है कोई भी गेस कर सकता है किन
नेटवर्क क्या है कोई
भी कोई भी गेस कर सकता है कि अनसिक्योर
नेटवर्क का मतलब क्या
है नहीं पर इंटरनेट आपका अनसिक्योर
नेटवर्क है बेसिकली वी कैन से ट इट इज ए
रिमोट एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन प्रोटोकॉल ट ऑफर्स
इंक्रिप्शन एंड इज सक्सेसर टू टेलनेट पहले
नेट का यूज किया जाता था लेकिन अभी एसएसएस
का यूज किया था रिमोट एक्सेस लेने के लिए
मशीन का इट इज टिपिकली यूज्ड फॉर रिमोट
एक्सेस टू सर्वर्स एंड सिस्टम्स व्हेन एवर
यू वांट टू कनेक्ट टू ए रिमोट सर्वर इट
कुड बी होस्टेड ऑन ए क्लाउड प्लेटफॉर्म और
ऑफसेट देन द प्रोटोकॉल ऑफ चॉइस इज एसएसएस
ज्यादातर आपको देखने को मिलता है
जगह पर क्या होस्टेड है और अगर मुझे उस
मशीन का रिमोट एक्सेस चाहिए व भी एक
सिक्योर वे में एक टनल के थ्रू काफी हाईली
सिक्योर तो हम यूज करते हैं एसएसए का
एसएसए यूज टीसीपी पोर्ट 22 बाय डिफॉल्ट
हाउ एवर लाइक अदर सर्विसेस इट कैन बी
कन्फर टू यूज एनी अदर ओपन टीसीपी पोर्ट
बाय डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट नंबर 22 को यूज करती है
आपकी एसएसएस लेकिन ड्यू टू सिक्योरिटी
कॉन्फिडेंस या आपके जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेट है
वो उसका पोर्ट नंबर भी चेंज कर सकते
हैं एसएसएस ऑथेंटिकेशन इज परफॉर्म्ड इन टू
वेज फर्स्ट इज पासवर्ड बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन
सेकंड वन इज की बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन अब जो
एसएसएस का ऑथेंटिकेशंस है वो दो तरीके से
परफॉर्म किया जाता है एक तो पासवर्ड बेस
ऑथेंटिकेशन मतलब जिसमें हम यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड का यूज करते हैं और की बेस
ऑथेंटिकेशन जिसमें हम की का यूज करते हैं
इनके बारे में समझते हैं पासवर्ड बेस
ऑथेंटिकेशन में होता क्या है द यूजर
एंटर्स ए पासवर्ड टू ऑथेंटिकेट देयर
आइडेंटिटी अपनी आइडेंटिटी को ऑथेंटिकेट
करने के लिए वह क्या करता है पासवर्ड का
यूज़ करता है और यूजर नेम का यूज़ करता है
दिस मेथड इज लेस सिक्योर देन अदर एज
पासवर्ड कैन बी इंटरसेप्टेड और गेस
क्योंकि वहां पर बलड फोर्स अटैक परफॉर्म
किया जा सकता है इसलिए यह मेथड क्या है
लेस सिक्योर है लेकिन पब्लिक की
ऑथेंटिकेशन मेथड है दिस इज द मोर सिक्योर
मेथड इट यूज ए पेयर ऑफ क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
कीज बेसिकली पब्लिक की एंड प्राइवेट की
पब्लिक और प्राइवेट की का पेयर यूज करता
है जिसकी वजह से दिस इज द मोस्ट सिक्योर
मेथड यहां पर क्या करते हो जब एसएसएस के
थ्रू आप लॉगिन करते हो अगर आप की बेस
ऑथेंटिकेशन यूज कर रहे हो उस केस में क्या
होता है आपको पासवर्ड एंटर करने की जरूरत
नहीं होती ऑटोमेटिक आप ऑथेंटिकेट कर जाते
हो और रिमोट एक्सेस आपको मिल जाता है
क्योंकि पब्लिक की स्टोर होती है सर्वर के
ऊपर और प्राइवेट की स्टोर होती है उस यूजर
के ऊपर जिसको रिमोट एक्सेस चाहिए वो पहले
ही कम्युनिकेशन सेटअप किया जाता है अब इस
तरह की की जानकारी जानने के लिए आपको क्या
करना है कि मेरी काली लिनक्स के प्लेलिस्ट
है उसमें शायद 10 10थ नंबर क्लास के बाद
कहीं पर मैंने वेरी डिटेल्स वे में एसएसएस
को पढ़ाया है कि एसएसएस होता क्या है कैसे
हम
करके भी और यूज करके भी दिखाया है पासवर्ड
बेस ऑथेंटिकेशन को सेटअप करके भी पासवर्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन को यूज करके भी मैंने दिखाया
है और पब्लिक और प्राइवेट की कहां कैसे
स्टोर होती है कैसे इसको कंफिल किया जाता
है यह सारी की सारी चीजें मैं अपनी काली
[संगीत]
बाद चेक कीजिए कि मैंने कहां पर एसएसएस
पढ़ाया है तो वहां पर आपको एसएसएस पढ़ाया
हुआ मिलेगा और काफी डिटेल्स में पढ़ाया
हुआ है वहां पर आपको सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
जाएगी कि ओके ये कैसे काम करता है कैसे हम
पोर्ट नंबर भी चेंज कर सकते हैं कैसे
पब्लिक प्राइवेट की जनरेट की जाती है कैसे
एक दूसरे साथ वो एक्सचेंज की जाती है यह
सारी सारी चीजें मैंने आपको पढ़ाई हुई है
मेरी क्लास के अंदर तो व्हेन ए क्लाइंट
ट्राइज टू लॉग इन दिस सर्वर यूज द पब्लिक
की टू वेरीफाई दैट क्लाइंट हैज द करेक्ट
प्राइवेट की ओके तो ये सारी चीज मैं आपको
बता चुका हू देयर आर टू वर्जंस ऑफ़ एसएसए
एसएसए व और एसएसएस टू एसएसए व द ओरिजिनल
वर्जन व्हिच इज कंसीडर्ड इनसिक्योर ड्यू
टू नॉन वल्नरेबल लेट से वीक इंक्रिप्शन इट
इज डिप्र केटेड एंड शुड नॉट बी यूज्ड इसको
हटा दिया गया है एसएसएस टू का यूज़ किया
जाता है द करंट एंड सिक्योर वर्जन
इंट्रोड्यूस्ड एज एन इंप्रूवमेंट ओवर
एसएसए व इट ऑफर स्ट्रांग इंक्रिप्शन
एल्गोरिथम्स एंड मोर सिक्योर की एक्सचेंज
प्रोटोकॉल्स ओके
तो यह आपका था एसएसएचएच के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन
वी कैन यूज मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स टू नमरे
इंफॉर्मेशन एज वेल एज परफॉर्म ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक्स टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
भी परफॉर्म करेंगे और ब्रूट फोर्स भी
ट्राई करेंगे अगर वो पासवर्ड बेस
ऑथेंटिकेशन होगा तो ओके तभी हम क्या कर
सकते हैं उसके थ्रू एक्सेस कर सकते हो
रिमोट एक्सेस ले सकते हो अगर आपको एसएसएस
के थ्रू कोई भी वल्नट मिलती है तो इ वेरी
पीव कैटेगरी वल्नरेबल है वेरी वेरी
क्रिटिकल सीवियर वलने बिलिटी है क्योंकि
आप डायरेक्टली सिस्टम को एक्सप्लोइट करके
सिस्टम के अंदर एक्सेस ले पा रहे हो ओके
तो अब इसका हम प्रैक्टिकल सेशन परफॉर्म
करते हैं तो प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए 10 बजे
तक क्लास को हम खत्म कर देंगे प्रैक्टिकली
भी प्लीज मुझे चैट सेक्शन में यह बताइए कि
सबको क्लियर है एसएसए होता क्या है कौन सा
पोर्ट यूज करता है बाकी और ज्यादा डिटेल
जानने के लिए आपको काली निक में जाके मेरी
प्लेलिस्ट में एसस की वीडियो को फाइंड आउट
करके पढ़ लीजिए
ओके च इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं और अभी
हम क्या करते हैं फिर से मशीन पर चेक करते
पिंग करते हैं
पिंग
19216811 हिट
एंटर यह
रहा डोंट वरी किसी को प्रो एफटीपी पर क्या
करना है अगर टी फाइंड आउट करनी है और उसके
ऊपर अगर वो वल्नरेबल है तो बात है ओके और
उस पर अगर एक्सेस गेन करना है तो वह हम
सीखने वाले हैं प्रीवियस वर्जन के ऊपर अभी
नहीं बाद में वो बाद कब आना जल्दी आने
वाला है ज्यादा टाइम नहीं आने वाले
नेक्स्ट 10 से 12 क्लासेस में व बाद वाली
जो बातें है ना वो स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी आपकी
जो बाद बाद में बोलता आ रहा हूं धोखा में
किसी चीज में आपको नहीं प्रोवाइड करने
केलिए सर आपने हमें झूठ बोला कि यह चीज
आपने नहीं पढ़ाई ऐसा कुछ नहीं होगा
ओके तो अभी हम बात करते हैं एसएसएस के
बारे में एसएसएस के बारे में कैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करते हैं तो एसएसएस
वर्जन मुझे अग यूज करना सबसे पहले मैं ए
मैप से फाइंड आउट करता एम 51 सर्विस वर्जन
देन उसके बाद
192.168
181 पोर्ट नंबर फाइंड आउट कर लेते हैं कि
अभी यहां पर अवेलेबल भी है पोर्ट नंबर 22
या नहीं है
ओके पोट नंबर 22 ओपन एसस
6.6.1 पव ओनट 2.1 यह ओके आपको यह फाइंड
आउट मिल गया अभी आप चाहो तो क्या कर सकते
हो एन मैप एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है फन पोर्ट
नंबर 22 उसके बाद हाइन हाइ फन स्क्रिप्ट
हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद एक एसएसए टू
हाइ फन एनम हाइ फन एल गोज एल्गोरिथम की
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए कि
कौन-कौन सी एल्गोरिथम यूज हो सकती है
कौन-कौन सी एल्गोरिथम यूज कर रहा होगा
एल्गोरिथम से रिलेटेड आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
चाहिए तो यह आपको प्रोवाइड करेगा यह
स्क्रिप्ट आपको प्रोवाइड करे
192.168
0.1 81 ट एंटर नाउ यह सारी की सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल गई एल्गोरिथम से
रिलेटेड ओके एसस टू एम एल्गो की एक्सचेंज
ये सारी सारी एल्गोरिथम यूज की जाती है
आपके एसएसएस के दवा ओके और ये इसके अंदर
भी ने गेस कर दिया आपको प्रोवाइड कर दिया
गेसिंग उसके बाद आप चाहो तो होस्ट की
पब्लिक की फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर
सकते हो विद द हेल्प ऑफ एक स्क्रिप्ट होती
है एन मैप अभी आपको अगर किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट
के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड पता करने
की स्क्रिप्ट एक्चुअल में काम कैसे करती
है तो एनम हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट आपको फिर
से बता देता हूं हाइन इंफो उसके बाद इक्वल
साइन अभी जो लास्ट स्क्रिप्ट हमने ने यूज
की एसएसए टू एनम उसके बाद एल गोज
एल्गोरिथम्स
एल
गोस ओके हिट एंटर ओके ओके ओके टारगेट आ
नहीं चाहिए स्क्रिप्ट हाई फन इनो ओके इनो
नहीं चा हेल्प होती है ईन आईन हेल्प होती
है
हिट एंटर यह देखो यह क्या करता है रिपोर्ट
द नंबर ऑफ एल्गोरिथम्स फॉर इंक्रिप्शन
कंप्रेशन दैट द टारगेट एसएसएस टू सर्वर
ऑफर्स इफ वर्बोसिटी इ सेट द ऑफर्ड
एल्गोरिथम्स आर ईच लिस्टेड बाय टाइप ओके
इफ द क्लाइंट्स टू सर्वर्स एंड सर्वर टू
क्लाइंट एल्गोरिथम लिस्टेड आर आइडेंट कल्स
देन द लिस्ट इज शोन ओनली वंस अंडर ए
कंबाइन टाइप ओके अब इसके बारे में आपको
ज्यादा रिसर्च करनी है तो खुद से पढ़ना
पड़ेगा ओके अभी नाउ एंड मैप क्योंकि आपको
खुद से भी रिसर्च करनी सीखनी पड़ेगी हाइन
प पोट 22 देन हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट देन एक एक और होती है एसएस
एच हाइन होस्ट
की होस्ट की उसके
बाद यहां पर आप क्या कर सकते हो आर्गुमेंट
प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो
हाइन हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट हाइन आर्गुमेंट
इक्वल
साइन नहीं तो स्पेस कीजिए आप
एसएसए होस्ट की इक्वल फुल यह एक चीट चट से
उठाया हुआ मैंने देखा था इसके बारे में
19216801
181 ओके हिट एंटर यह
देखिए ये आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है होस्ट
कीज ये देखो एसस की होस्ट की दिस इ द
पब्लिक की आपको प्रोवाइड करता है प्राइवेट
की आपको य प्रोवाइड नहीं करता ओके यह रहा
यह पब्लिक की आपको प्रोवाइड करता है
क्लियर प्राइवेट की आपके पास नहीं होगी एक
और चीज होती है एसस ऑथेंटिकेशन मेथड की एक
स्क्रिप्ट होती है एन मैप हाइन प प
202 देन उसके बाद हाइन हाइ फन
स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद एस एसस एच हाइ फन ओथ
हाइन
मेथड मेथड से रिलेटेड आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
फांड आट है और आर्गुमेंट में आपके पास अभी
यह यूज नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि हमारे पास यह
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए मेथड से
रिलेटेड फाइंड आउट करने के हमारे पास क्या
होना चाहिए यूजर्स नेम हमारे पास होना
चाहिए तो आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो जब आपके
पास आर्गुमेंट में उसकी यूजर्स नेम हो तो
अभी आप क्या एमएसएफ कंसोल का भी यूज कर
सकते हो तो एमएसएफ कंसोल में कुछ मॉड्यूस
होते हैं
एमएसएफ कंसोल यह राइट एंटर इट विल टेक
टाइम तब तक हम क्या करते हैं एक और टैब को
ओपन करते हैं एमएसएफ कंसोल स्ट स्टार्ट
होने से पहले यह रहा अगर हम एसएसएस को यूज
करना चाहते हैं तो एसएसएस को यूज करने का
एक ही तरीका होता है कैसे मैं आपको बता
देता हूं
देखो एसएसएस एच कमांड उसके बाद यूजर नेम
मेंशन करते हैं उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
मेंशन यूजर नेम
अभी अभी यूजर नेम मेरे पास तो है नहीं है
क्योंकि अभी मेरे पास अगर यूजर नेम नहीं
है तो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं रूट
रेट वन
9216 181 ये आपका आईपी एड्रेस होता है इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो एसएसए के
थ्रू कनेक्शन एब्लिश कर सकते हो रिमोट
कनेक्शन यूजर नेम आपका कोई भी हो सकता है
यहां पर जो आपको पता हो आपके पास
इंफॉर्मेशन हो अब सिंपली मैं एंटर करता
हूं क्योंकि मेरे पास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है
लेकिन मैं देखता हूं क्या ब्लैंक पासवर्ड
है हिट एंटर यह देखिए द ऑथेंटिकेशन
ऑथेंटिसिटी ऑफ होस्ट शोन सो इज
एस्टाब्लिशड ईडी फिंगरप्रिंट सोन सो यह है
दिस की इज नॉट नोन टू एनी अदर यूजर्स एंड
आर यू शर वांट टू कंफिल कंटिन्यू
कनेक्टिंग यस शर यस मैंने यस कर दिया ओके
परमानेंटली एडिड टू द लिस्ट ऑफ नोन अभी
मुझे पासवर्ड चाहिए अभी मेरे पास पासवर्ड
करेक्ट होगा तो यह क्या है
उसकी जो एक फाइल होती
है ऑथराइजेशन होस्ट या कुछ एक ऑथेंटिकेशन
होस्ट करके एक फाइल होती है जो आपको
मिलेगी डॉट एसएसएस डायरेक्टरी के अंदर तो
वहां पे जाके इसकी एंट्री हो जाएगी अभी
मेरे पास कुछ है नहीं मैं सिंपली ट एंटर
कर दिया कुछ नहीं मेरे पास पासवर्ड ही
नहीं है रॉन्ग पासवर्ड परमिशन डिनाइड
क्योंकि मेरे पास पासवर्ड नहीं है अगर
मेरे पास सही से पासवर्ड होता इसका तो
इसके अंदर मैं एंट्री कर जाता अभी हम क्या
करते हैं इसके वर्जन की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं विद द हेल्प
ऑफ एस तो
सर्च उसके बाद टाइप उसके बाद टाइप कौन सा
है मेरा
ऑक्सल
ऑक्सल देन उसके बाद नेम नेम मेरा क्या है
एसएसए हिट एंटर अभी बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
यहां पर अवेलेबल मैं अभी मुझे क्या वर्जन
फाइंड आउट करना है यह देखो इसके अंदर भी
अवेलेबल से एक मॉड्यूल ऑक्सल स्कैनर एसएसए
एसएसए लॉगइन अगर आपका
एसएसए की बेस्ड ओ सॉरी पासवर्ड बेस्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन को यूज कर रहा है तो आप क्या
कर सकते हो विधि हेल्प ऑफ दिस मॉड्यूल आप
ट्राई कर सकते हो ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक इस
मॉड्यूल को आप यूज करोगे इसके अंदर एक पास
अंडरस्कोर फाइल होगी उसके अंदर आपको क्या
करना है आपकी पासवर्ड्स की वर्ड लिस्ट ऐड
करनी है आपको पता है कैसे यूज करना है
क्योंकि काफी टाइम से हम इसको यूज कर रहे
हैं उसके अंदर एक होगी यूजर अंडरस्कोर
फाइल यूजर अंडर फाइल के अंदर आपको क्या
करनी है जो यूजर्स नेम है उसकी वर्ड लिस्ट
ऐड करनी है देन आर होस्ट के अंदर आईपी
एड्रेस का ऐड करना टारगेट का देन मैं चेक
करना है कि आपका जो पोर्ट नंबर है वो 22
है या नहीं है देन उसके बाद आप सिंपली
क्या एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हो अगर आपको
सक्सेसफुली क्या गेन एक्सेस मिलता तो यहां
पर आपको सेल भी प्रोवाइड कर देगा मतलब
आपको एक्सेस मिल जाएगा वहीं से क्या सेल
को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो ओके
एक टर्मिनल आपको मिल जाएगा यहां पर इस केस
में ओके नाउ मैं इसको यूज नहीं कर रहा अभी
मैं फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
यहां पर वर्जन की इंफॉर्मेशन तो वर्जन की
इंफॉर्मेशन इसके लिए यूज 15 में यूज
करूंगा यूज
हिट एंटर नाउ अभी शो
ऑप्शन यह रहा ट यहां पर ज्यादा कुछ
इनफॉर्म सेट करनी नहीं है हमें आर होस्ट
सेट करना ओनली बस
सेट आर होस्ट
19216811 इन कोर्सेस में मैंने स्पेशली यह
ध्यान दिया हुआ है खासकर एन्यूमरेशन के
अंदर कि आप ऑटोमेशन प्लस में मैनुअल दोनों
तरीकों का यूज करें अभी आप बोलो सर
ऑटोमेशन आपने कब यूज किया भैया एमएसएफ को
आप जब यूज करते हो तो पूरा पूरा आपका
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग को ऑटोमेटिक ली करता
है यह सारे काम आप ऑटोमेटिक ले करर ो आपको
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस सेट करना है मॉड्यूल
सेलेक्ट करना है और रन करना है यह तो
ऑटोमेट ऑटोमेशन ही है ऐसा कोई ऑटोमेशन
नहीं हो कि सिर्फ आप ओनली टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस दो सब कुछ करके दे दो नहीं इतनी तो
मेहनत आपको करनी पड़ेगी देखो अभी मैं
सिंपली रन कर देता हूं अ देखिए
फिंगरप्रिंट एसएसए सो सो ये इसका वर्जन
क्या है एसएसएस 2.0 एट यूज कर रहा है देन
ये रहा सर्विस वर्जन यह है वेंडर ओपन
बीएसडी है प्रोटोकॉल एसएसएस है ओपन एसएसएस
का यूज किया जा रहा है न टू मशीन है वर्जन
14.04 है यहां पर तो काफी डिटेल्स में
आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई देखो बहुत
ज्यादा डिटेल्स में इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई देखो
यह रही यह
रही यह कंप्रेशन उसका यूज कर रहा है ये
रहा ये रहा डेपके वाली भी इंफॉर्मेशन
मेंशन की है देखो मतलब बहुत ज्यादा आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां
आ गी क्योंकि आपको ज्यादातर इंफॉर्मेशन
क्या देखो ये र सर्विस वर्जन आपके पास आ
गई ठीक आपका एसएसएस के थ्रू आपको एंट्री
नहीं मिलती लेकिन आप इन वर्जन के बेसिस पर
क्या कर सकते हो एक्सप्लोइट करने की कोशिश
कर सकते हो एक्सेस गेन करने की कोशिश कर
सकते हो चाहे व कर्नल एक्सप्लोइट हो चाहे
आपका वह सर्विस एक्सप्लोइट हो वह सारे भी
आप क्या कर सकते हो परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
लेकिन अभी हमारा टॉपिक क्या है एसएसए और
ये अभी अभी हम क्या करते इसको फिर से सर्च
करते हैं
एसएसए और अभी मैं आपको एसएसएस वर्जन चेक
करके दिखा दिया मैंने आपको और यह रहा यह
रहा यह रहा अभी यूज
11 सो
ऑप्शन यह रहा अभी यहां पर हमें चेक करना
चेक चेक फॉर फाल्स नेगेटिव नो नो नो सेट
नहीं आर सेट करना प 22 सेट यूजर नेम अभी
हम सेट करने हमारे पास है नहीं तो सिंपली
इसमें भी हम होस्ट सेट करते हैं ओनली आर
होस्ट
19216811 हिट एंटर इसको भी मैं रन करके
देख लेता हूं कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है
फेलियर ओके प्लीज पॉपलेट डीबी ऑल यूजर्स
यूजर फाइल यूजर नेम अगर मेरे पास ये
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी तभी यह आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
प्रोवाइड करेगा अदर वाइज यह मॉड्यूल आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड नहीं करेगा क्योंकि
इसको यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड की आवश्यकता है
ओके विदाउट इसके यह काम नहीं करेगा तो इस
तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो यहां से
फाइंड आउट कर सकते कि मेरे लिए स्विचेबल
कौन सी होगी खासकर देखो आपको फजिंग नहीं
करनी है अभी के लिए ओनली स्कैनिंग कर रहे
हो आप स्कैनिंग के लिए तो स्कैनर वाले
मॉड्यूल ऑक्सल स्कैनर ही ट्राई करो फजर
अभी मत ट्राई क्योंकि आप फजिंग नहीं कर
रहे ओके तो यह तरीके थे आपके एसएसए के
सबको समझ में आया एसएसएस के थ्रू आप कैसे
कर सकते
हो
एवरीवन यह एसएसएस की कहानी भाई
ओके और एसएसएस के थ्रू आप रिमोट कैसे
एक्सेस लोगे मशीन के अंदर उसके बाद आपको
अगर लो लेवल एक्सेस है मतलब आपके पास
ज्यादा प्रिविलेज नहीं है तो उसको हम मोर
प्रिविलेज में कैसे कन्वर्ट करेंगे जिस
टेक्निक को हम बोलते हैं प्रिविलेज एस्किन
मतलब लो लेवल से हाई लेवल में कैसे
कन्वर्ट करेंगे यह सारी हम इंफॉर्मेशन
अपकमिंग क्लास में जल्द ही करने वाले हैं
अभी आप ज्यादा दूर नहीं हो समझ लेना अगर
आप लोगों को मैं हिंट प्रोवाइड कर देता
हूं जब भी मैं आपको बोलता हूं कि आज से हम
सेक्शन फोर सिस्टम हैकिंग स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं तो समझ लेना सिस्टम हैकिंग आपकी
क्या है वहां पर विंडो और लिनक्स मशीन को
हैक करना सिखाया जाएगा मल्टीपल वल्नरेबल
के थ्रू ओके जहां पर आपको इन्हेरेंट वनबिल
नेटवर्क बेस अटैक क्लाइंट बेस अटैक और
आपके जो एसक्यूएल के थ्रू जहां पर आपका
कमांड इंजेक्शन आ गया जहां आपका और भी
तरीके हैं जिनके थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो
मशीन के अंदर एक्सेस लोगे एक्सेस लेने के
बाद फिर फर्द अगर और कोई मशीने होगी उनके
ऊपर एक्सेस लेने की कोशिश करोगे पिवेट
जिसको हम बोलते हैं उसके बाद जब आप पूरी
हैकिंग कंप्लीट कर लोगे अपना फेज कंप्लीट
कर लो तो ट्रैक को कैसे क्लियर करते हैं
वोह भी मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
कि आपने जो जो किया उसके ट्रैक सबूत कैसे
मिटाते हैं ताकि आप पकड़ में ना आए
ओके
यस तो सबको क्लियर है प्रिविलेज ये एसएसए
एन्यूमरेशंस अभी के लिए इतना काफी है आप
लोगों के लिए एसएसएस और एफटीपी के बारे
में यस लॉ क्लियर करना
सिखाऊंगा रोनी मैं सिखाऊंगा सिखाऊंगा यार
सिखाऊंगा आप
लोग नहीं तो आप
डीबी जो एक्सप्लो डीबी पर जाके व जो वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक है अगर आपको कोई सर्विस का
वर्जन मिल रहा है या आपको अपने ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का वर्जन मिल रहा है तो वर्जन
स्पेसिफिक वनटी वहां पर फाइंड आउट करके
उसके बाद वो भी एक प्रोसेस है कि वहां पर
आपको एक्सप्लोइट मिल गया लेकिन एक्सप्लोइट
को आपको पहले रीड आउट करना है समझने की
कोशिश करना है कि एक्सप्लोइट में मुझे कुछ
चेंजेज करने की या कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन ऐड करने
की जरूरत है या नहीं है अब उसके बाद
इंफॉर्मेशन ऐड करने की जरूरत आप
इंफॉर्मेशन ऐड करने के बाद उसको कंपाइल
कैसे करना है कंपाइल करने के बाद उसको
डिलीवर कैसे करना है एजट करने कैसे करना
है अभी हो सकता है कि अब ट्रस्टेड
प्लेटफॉर्म कुछ ही होते हैं जहां पर आपको
क्या है वैलिड एक्सप्लोइट मिलते हैं कहीं
पर जब गिट हब पर क्या करते हो कि आपको
वैलिड एक्सप्लो मिलने के चांसेस कम होते
हैं ओके तो वह भी एक तरीका एक टेक्निक्स
है कंपाइलेशन डी कंपाइलेशन वाला जो खास
करके तो मैं आपको बताऊंगा सेफली कैसे कर
सकते हो कहां से कर सकते हो आई विल
एक्सप्लेन आई विल
टीच तो रोनी सिंह अगर नई वनटी आपको फाइंड
आउट करनी है तो आपको मैं आपको बताता हूं
एक तरीका है आपको सबसे पहले उसका सोर्स
कोड मालूम करना है सोर्स कोड में आपको
क्या करना है सारे कोड को समझना है उसके
बाद उसके के अंदर आपको क्या करना
है लूप फाइंड आउट करने लूप होल फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करने है जिसको हम बोलते हैं
रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग उसके बाद उसमें
मॉडिफिकेशन करके देखना है देन उसके बाद एज
पर योर नीड आपको इतनी सारी चीजें आती है
उसको उस कोड को क्रैक करके सारी चीज आपको
आती है तो फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी भी
सिस्टम को हैक कर सकते हो किसी भी सिस्टम
की वनटी को फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो जिसको हम
बोलते जीरो डेबल नेटी वो आपको फाइंड आउट
करनी पड़ेगी अब उसके लिए आपको सी भी आना
चाहिए उस आपको एक्सप्लोर डेवलपमेंट भी आनी
चाहिए रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग भी आनी चाहिए
आपको और अच्छी खासी नक् और विंडोज की
अच्छी खासी नॉलेज होनी चाहिए ऐसे नहीं कि
जस्ट मुझे एफटीपी और एसस के बारे में पता
है यह सारी फ नॉलेज होने के बावजूद उसके
पास आपको थोड़ा बहुत एक्सपीरियंस होना
चाहिए तो यह सारी चीजें होने के बावजूद आप
वो चीज फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो अदर वाइज
वरना तो आपको ऑलरेडी जो एक्सप्लोइटेड
वनबिल है आप उन्हीं के बेस पर ट्राई करना
होगा या फिर लेटेस्ट जो
न्यूज होती है जहां पर आपको साइबर
सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड या लेटेस्ट जो पैच
अपडेट होते हैं लेटेस्ट जो वनटी मिलती है
या आप उनसे अपडेट होना पड़ेगा फिर या उनसे
आपको काम चलाना पड़ेगा आपके पास दो ही
ऑप्शन है
ओके किसी का और कोई सवाल पूछिए
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
तो आपका वेट जल्दी खत्म होने वाला डोंट
वरी बट स्ट्रेंथ के अलावा तो मुझे शायद
अभी मैं आपके लिए प्रॉमिस नहीं करूंगा अगर
आपके यही 35 41 स्टूडेंट्स ही हैं तो मैं
कोर्स को
डिस्कंटेंट में
हूं अभी तो मैं कोर्स को डिस कंटिन्यू
करने के लिए पूरे मूड में हूं क्योंकि
मुझे इंटरेस्ट नहीं आ रहा पढ़ाने में सीधी
सी बात य है यार आप
लोग सिस्टम एन्यूमरेशन करवाइए
तो सिस्टम एमेशन तो मैं के हम करवाएंगे
लोकल एन्यूमरेशन जो बोल रहे हो ना आप
करवाएंगे करवाएंगे
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज होता ना उसके लिए
आपको सिस्टम एन्यूमरेशन करना पड़ता जहां
पर आपको नेटवर्क की इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको उसके वर्जन की इंफॉर्मेशन उसके हॉट
फिक्सस की इंफॉर्मेशन उनकी बात कर रहे हो
ना
कार्बन उसी की बात चल रही है
ना नहीं बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग कंटिन्यू नहीं
होगी क्योंकि वहां पर आपका रिस्पांस ऐसा
ही था
यस यस मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
अन पॉपुलर ट्रेडर की बात करते व सर प्लीज
प्लीज अभी आप लोग भी तो यार मेरे को
कंट्रीब्यूट कीजिए
ना आप लोग मेरे बारे में नहीं सोच
मैं तो फी के रूप में ओनली स्टूडेंट ही
मांग रहा हूं ता क्या अगर मैं कहीं पर
बाहर ऐसे ऑफलाइन खोल के बैठ जाता और मैं
किसी को ऐसे बढ़ाने लग जाता ना अपना टाइम
देता कि भई मैं वीक में टू क्लास लूंगा और
फिजिकली आगे लूंगा तो बताऊ अगर दो फ्लोर
की बिल्डिंग हो तो व भी फुल हो जाती वहां
पर इतने ज्यादा स्टूडेंट होते
तो जिनकी जरूरत पड़ेगी मैं बता दूं
डिस्ट्रॉय अदर वाइज मैं जब बूट कैंप्स
करवाऊंगी आई विल प्लान समथिंग बूट कैमस
रिलेटेड तो उसमें भी मैं आपको बता दूंगा
जहां जहां पर बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग की जरूरत
पड़ेगी जहां पर पॉपुलर होंगे जरूरत होंगी
अदर वाइज वरना तो फिर आपको एज पर
रिक्वायरमेंट और एज पर योर नॉलेज जहां पर
आपको अपने काम को आसान करना है जहां आप
चाहते हो कि मुझे मैं काफी लेजी हूं और
लेजी होने के साथ-साथ मुझे बार-बार टाइप
करना पसंद नहीं आता तो आप अपनी सारी चीजों
को सीखने के बावजूद अपनी जो होती है ना कि
मेरी टेक्निक्स है उन टेक्निक्स को आप
ऑटोमेशन तरीके से अपने खुद की स्क्रिप्ट
लिख के अपना टूल खुद का बना के बैस में और
अपने पास रख सकते हो किसी को सेल करने की
जरूरत नहीं है यह खुद की टेक्निक है जस्ट
आपको हिट एंटर करना वो सारी चीज आपको
फाइंड आउट करके दे
देगा एनी वन किसी और कोई सवाल तो
बताइए य तो मैं देख चुका हूं कि क्वालिटी
की गदर नहीं
है कुछ टाइम पहले मैं बात नहीं करूंगा तो
मैं
अभी आप सब शायद समझ गए होग मैं कहां बोल
रहा हूं कि किसी ने सफ क्या बोलते टाइटल
ऐसा डालेंगे कि एक मिनट में हमने इसको हैक
कर लिया और उसमें क्या है कि प्री सेटअप
मशीन है या सडन को यूज करेंगे सडन से
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल उस चीज को दिखाएंगे या
एमएसएफ को यूज करेंगे उसको दिखाएंगे और
बोला हो
गया मतलब टाइटल ऐसा रखो जहां पर लोग
आएंगे तो लिंक दिन पर कंटिन्यू ट्राई करते
जा प्रोफाइल भेजते रहिए और डेफिनेटली आपको
एक दिन मिल
जाएगी सुरजीत जी
आपको अभी क्या है कि इंटर्नशिप की तो बहुत
मारामारी है मतलब कोई देने के लिए तैयार
भी नहीं है सबको क्या नाभी इंडिया में तो
एक ट्रेंड बन गया है सबको क्या है कि अपनी
उसमें रिक्वायरमेंट में भी क्या डालते हैं
ओससीपी सीआई एसपी वो डालते जिसका सीएसपी
करने के लिए एटलीस्ट फ टू 10 इयर्स
एक्सपीरियंस होना चाहिए वो उनकी बिगनर
लेवल डिमांड है तो भाई अभी यह डिमांड कैसे
फुलफिल होगी क्योंकि इंडिया में सबको क्या
है कि पैसे कम देने हैं काम ज्यादा करो ना
है तो बहुत प्रॉब्लम है इस मामले
में बताइए और कुछ नहीं है तो फिर सेशन को
हम एंड कर देते हैं ओके आई विल नॉट वेस्ट
योर टाइम और नेक्स्ट सेशन के बारे में अभी
मैं आपको नहीं बता रहा क्योंकि मैं लूंगा
या नहीं लूंगा
सर मैं डीसीपीटी कोर्स कर रहा हूं कौन सा
एंड्राइड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
कहां से कर रहे हो आप तो अभी कोर्स तो
ऑनलाइन है नहीं लाइव है नहीं
बताइए कहां से कर रहे हो अभी ऑनलाइन तो है
नहीं बैच तो कब का खत्म हो
गया कहां से चल रहा है यार कौन सा एड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट की बात कर रहे हो
ना ओके वीपीटी के ऊपर ओके ओके आई एम सॉरी
फॉर ट सम
ओके साइबर क्राइम का कोई वीडियो कोर्स
आएगा आ गया ना डीसीसीआई आप कर सकते हो तो
इधर से आप गो टू डे फोनिक्स एंड य र चलो
इधर ही बता देता
आपको डे
फोनिक्स सिंपली आपको क्या करना है इधर ओके
य डेफ अकेडमी
देन गो टू योर य पर सिंपली सर्च करना इधर
लास्ट
में डीसीसीआई और आप अभी लिंक है ना इसको
भी यह रहा आप
इसको सिलेबस को देखिए और शायद 11 तारीख से
स्टार्ट होने वाली
है आई कांट से मैं नहीं कह सकता अभी तो
ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं बाय बाय टेक
केयर एंड गुड नाइट और देखते हैं फिर
कंटिन्यूएशन और नॉट कंटिन्यूएशन हम देखते
हैं ओके तो बाय बाय टेक केयर
एंड बाय बाय गुड
नाइट m